Let me show you where we left off
because I did fix one thing.
Uh we're not doing the LM [ __ ]
stream today. That will be sometime in
the next weekish.
We have to fix scudter grass first. I
want to make sure we have one thing at
least done. Um,
let me show you what I've been working
on.
every single LM missed this, by the way.
You have to restore the old stream at
the end. Oneline bug. completely
unreadable error message.
Welcome, Pepe.
So, yeah, with this now, now we can
actually run it. Um, the issue that I'm
having at the moment is
so this state buffer out, this gets
populated correctly. I've tested it, but
for whatever reason, this does not seem
to be consuming and using state
correctly.
So
yeah, that's kind of weird.
Let me see if I can remember how I was
testing this. I believe it was I just
rebuild.
I believe We're going to get at least 1
mil SPS um off of the eval loop from
this and then we can probably get more
when we apply to train in the optimizer.
I think it's also this is only going to
be hard once. Like once I figure this
out for one chunk of the network, the
rest is easy.
Okay. Yep. So what this is showing
essentially is the output of the buffer
is always the same.
the idea is that you have um the state
input and then puffer copies it in
and then it replays the graph and then
copies it out. And I put these syncs in
here just to make sure there's nothing
async weird going on. And then I look at
the first item of the output and there's
nothing there. And I've also I've tested
that this buffer is outputting
correctly. Like you can set stuff in the
loop and it works. So I believe that
somehow then the network
it's not like using the state in a
reasonable way.
Doesn't make a ton of sense to me.
Um like we get the state out from state
input here. Actually,
It's getting sort of set, right? How
does it get the 0.25 in it?
Is it just like a steady state thing?
Maybe 0.25. It's like an attractor.
Well, I can just do the Hang on. I know
what I can do.
We can test this versus the
the previous implementation, right?
Then we do state out first item like
this.
Okay. So this is what happens when I use
the real network. We can see we get 0.25
but then it actually changes right and
it evolves.
So, how is it then that this
is it not getting fed back in correctly
or something? Like
that would seem odd to me.
I was trying to figure out if I could
get this done off stream in the evening
last night and um I fixed the one bug
from before and I just couldn't finish
this one.
Okay. So this is saying that the first
item is zero
and then the first item is 0.25. Right?
rap state
this never gets overwritten Okay.
That's what it's going to be, man. We
fight cudigraphs today.
I'm going to do a stream like in the
next several days because Car Pathy
tweets it like fine.
I strongly strongly suspect that the guy
is like
I don't know. He's like done all of his
stuff and now it I don't know. I'll be
shocked
if it's actually good. And of course,
when Carathy tweets [ __ ] like every
[ __ ] like just jumps on it to
justify them being lazy and not
bothering to learn anything.
I could be dramatically wrong, but so
far the models have been worse than
useless.
I solved a couple of the problems from
yesterday offmarket. Now, there's just
something weird going on with the um the
traced graph, but we can run this traced
graph table.
I'd like to be less mad about all the
LLM stuff, honestly. I'd like to just be
able to like, you know, chill and ignore
stuff and being clear of mind to just
focus and create like awesome stuff. Um,
but for whatever reason, it's like
a lot of the stuff I build, I build out
of spite most of the time. So, I don't
know if I'm capable of just chilling and
building all this. So, me,
it bothers me though. It bothers me.
What could this be that like we know
that this Well, actually,
I can't even print this out, can I?
You know, I have an idea. Here's how we
can test this.
We're going to add one to the buffer and
we're going to see what happens um to
the output
If it outputs every time, then it's not
getting copied to the input.
Like if it still outputs 0.25
There's no way it maps every output to
0.25, right?
Because I guess that would also do it.
Yeah, I said I'm going to do uh I'll do
a stream. I have a project in mind that
would take me like a few days. Um
I'm going to get So what? Let me be
clear. When I do this, I'm going to give
it a genuine attempt. Like, I'm going to
set it up in the best possible way for
it to succeed. So, nobody's going to be
able to say like, "Oh, you just designed
this in a way to fail or you didn't do
it properly." Like, I'm going to be very
clear about it, but I do not have high
expectations for this. Like honestly,
the most likely the most likely scenario
in my head is just that everybody really
likes when these models tell them how
good they are at coding and how smart
they are and they like feeling super
productive even though they have no idea
what they're doing and they're just
building complete and utter [ __ ] and
in the process actually not bothering to
even understand things that would allow
them to learn and build things that are
useful. I think it's just ly lazy
laziness, sickopency, and general
idiocy. That's my guess.
I guess it's technically possible that
one generation of models like happened
to be the huge leap, but this is what
people have been telling me since GPT
3.5. They were [ __ ] programmers that
didn't know what they were doing back
then. And I'm almost guaranteeing you
they were they're [ __ ] programmers that
don't know what they're doing now,
which is pretty impressive as well
coming from me cuz like I am nowhere
near skill cap. Like I could be 10 times
better than I am now. Not like with LLMs
at all. Just straight up be 10 times
better at what I do.
But honestly for me the biggest um I
think the e the best thing that I could
do is if I could just figure out a way
to consistently have more energy for my
work that would be bigger than anything
else because I genuinely I really like
my work and Um, mostly the cap for me is
I just get burnt out by all the stuff
that I deal with. And stuff like this
burns me out super quick. Like I sat
down yesterday, why the heck did I need
to take a week and a half vacation? I
never take that much time off. And then
I sit down and immediately I go, "Oh,
this is why
you know
I don't know if they will just by
scaling them. Man,
I wouldn't be surprised if they just
don't under the current paradigm. Like
they're going to be useful. They're
going to be valuable.
But like the whole concept of like let's
just offload our thinking and abstract
away everything to a model is just
fundamentally stupid to me.
I would way rather like these models are
designed in the laziest way possible.
Let's say that we got genuinely smart
models. Okay. Like assuming we have not
completely just replaced all of
humanity. Then my like what I would like
to have is I would like to have
something that actually feels like a
smart assistant, not like just doing
[ __ ] for me, right?
Like if I could just get the answer to
every niche technical question I have,
not like how do I do this piece of
logic, but like every niche technical
question I have um with perfect accuracy
or at least with verifiability, like
that would be way more useful than
something that like kind of spits out a
bunch of code but then gets it wrong
half the time and like misses basic
stuff. Like there are ways to make these
things useful, but it's not the
direction that people have gone in. like
it's essentially the dumbest, laziest,
like most idiot-prone way um of using
these models has become the default.
And I don't feel like building that type
of stuff either because I have other
things I can be doing that I feel are
more valuable, right? Like I think RL is
going to be as important uh if not like
more important long term than language
models are.
It's not going to be the super flashy
type of a thing, right? It's not going
to be the super sexy stuff that you hear
about, but it's going to be everywhere.
Okay, so look at this, right? The input
and the output buffers are working
correctly because otherwise this would
not work properly, right? Because this
gets incremented by one.
Wait, hang on.
let me just uh let's double check one
thing here which is going to be
Okay. Yeah, it actually I think is fine
cuz before it double. Yeah, that's fine.
Okay. So the reason that I did this is I
wanted to make sure that the input and
output handles did not get messed up
because if you mess up the pointer
somehow
uh the way that this tracing works right
is it just it replays the exact
operations on the exact memory
addresses. So these pointers have to not
get messed up.
So,
Honestly, I hate to say it, but like
kind of carpathic.
Like there are other people that hyped
it up, but he was the most legitimate
person that hyped all this [ __ ] up.
But like Carpathy has always had split
takes, right? He's done some like
Carpathy has always been the type of guy
who's had some absolutely amazing stuff
and then some absolutely stupid stuff.
Like I remember I remember back when he
was a PhD student, one of the things he
said is that he didn't want better
programming languages. He wanted better
idees.
I still remember that back from when I
was like
16 or 17 at most. It's like what the
hell? Why? And like maybe I just don't
understand it. And today I'm still
thinking like that's like crazy.
Honestly, the stuff from Carpathy that I
like the most are all of his uh not his
like takes on stuff, right? I like his
uh I like his simple implementations and
explanations of stuff. Those are
worldclass and fantastic. And also a lot
of his research from when he was a PhD
student as well. Like when he was doing
active research was awesome,
right? Also, uh like his teaching stuff
was amazing as well.
I mean, there are very few people that I
have more respect for. And even if it is
the case that this ends up being
completely stupid, I'll still have a ton
of respect for him, right? Like, because
he has all this other stuff.
Educator. See, I don't think that that's
fair though
because like if you can build simple
stuff, that's not just educational. That
is how you build worldclass software.
That is how you take hard problems that
are opaque and that like nobody can
understand and cannot advance and that
is how you actually bring them into the
light. Right? That is exactly I am doing
that with puffer lip. That's my goal and
it's not educational. Right? it happens
to be the case that there's overlap
where doing this it makes it more
accessible and also like it brings
people into the field and that's awesome
but like that's not that wasn't even my
primary goal starting puffer lift right
it was to make RL actually work at scale
and it's just that in my mind the way to
do that is you take something very
complicated you make it very simple and
then you can understand it fully and
that is a way better base to build off
of than just saying ah screw it we're
going to go fast and we're going to like
you know chuck a bunch stuff on the wall
and not actually having any sort of
observability about what you're building
because I've heard that take from other
people before and I don't think that
that gives Carpathy anywhere near enough
credit
Yeah, if I don't build Puffer, literally
nobody will do this. RL will continue to
suck. And this awesome technology that
is straight out of sci-fi that we have
seen proven will just not be there. It
will not be there in a form that you can
easily use or in the form that it should
exist for possibly decades, possibly
ever.
That's something that I had to learn
during my PhD. You know, during my PhD,
I thought I would stop building Neural
MMO after a couple years because I
figured that DeepMind would just go like
see what I was doing, build it. It was a
pretty obvious next step to do, but
instead they hard trolled. They did a
bunch of projects that were infinitely
dumber in their direction with way more
resources.
Um, and nobody else remotely did the
obvious thing.
It is literally the case, right? It's
not the case that there are a room full
of scientists working on every hard and
important problem out there. It is
literally the case often that if you are
smart and have an idea if you don't do
it, it will not exist. Nobody will do it
ever and it just will not be something
that is available in the world.
So like I guess in some sense just the
amount of ineptitude I see around me
it's very disappointing because you know
if there if if people thought this way
like we would live in a dramatically
better world but at the same time given
that we live in the world that we do
like there's a huge amount of
opportunity to build stuff and to
improve upon things.
The thing is you're fighting upstream a
lot of the time because the default way
that things are done and the way that
things are set up for you to work is
fundamentally wrong, right? That is the
reason most of the time that things
don't exist because the way that things
are set up make it hard to build stuff
that matters.
Spend some time over the holidays
learning about puffer lab. Would you
where would you point a midunk who is
also a noob? Well, do you know how to
program? Um, it's I have guides. So
rather than give people the same like
poorly worded advice on stream
repeatedly, I just wrote a couple really
high quality articles.
Read both of these
these two and also start the buffer. It
helps a lot
more resources to deploy. Yeah, but like
first use what happens when you have a
hundred engineers and you fail at
something and I have I'm one person and
I do it like
that kind of screws up the scaling
proposition, right?
I'm not using today, Roger. Today I'm
doing CUDA stuff. I have a better
project in mind. Um I have a much better
project in mind for Opus that I'm going
to do once I have this CUDA stuff done.
But this is probably going to be a full
day of hell. Um, for context, if I
manage to do this, this will kill all of
the kernel launch overhead in Puffer
Live. Uh, and this should get us plus 1
to 2 million steps per second. Hey,
well,
okay. So we have
right the other possibility here
there's one other thing I wanted to test
before I got on that end goal will help
us understand financial markets yeah
somewhat we have a few active contracts
in finance and commerce right now
already
they're sort of small but already like
I'd say meaningful
a lot more can be done though heck if
somebody wanted to do I think the best
thing we could do without having any
sort of conflict of interest is if we
did like an MMO type market. That would
be a really cool thing to simulate
social working. What's that mean? Unity
of command.
They control. Well, I really like open
source because like you just you get
self- selecting people who are here
because they give a [ __ ]
And there is even financial incentive
like I do hire people out of our
contributors. I don't go advertising it
because I don't like to incentivize
people to do free work by like dangling
the carrot that maybe there will be paid
work. But it is also true that I do hire
people out of um out of the
contributors. Like there are a couple
people right now in my that come to mind
that I will pull for the next few
contracts.
There's really no other way to vet
people. Like the only proof of can you
do good work is are you doing good work?
So this is what I wanted to do. I just
wanted to see if the output still maps
everything to 0.25.
not organic.
That would be so funny if they actually
paid everybody. You would think that
would leak though, right?
I mean, I'm not a conspiracy theorist,
right? I would think that that would
leak.
Ah, look at this. Everything mapped to
0.25. You see this?
Okay, let's leave that there because
that's going to tell us something
Anybody see anything wrong with this?
The way this is set up, I think it's got
to be in the policy, right?
Lots of low quality PRs.
Uh, I mean, not really because
I just ignore [ __ ] that's obviously bad.
It's pretty easy to tell, right? It's
like people that are hanging around
either the Discord a bunch or the stream
a bunch and are actually putting the
time in to learn stuff and to build
environments.
Like the stuff I'm doing, if you are
already a reasonably experienced
programmer, it's actually not that hard
to learn. like you actually have to
listen is the thing.
But a lot of the stuff I'm doing, well,
I'm not going to say it's not hard. It
is very simple though.
Like I've had multiple people just
listen to what I've been telling them,
start writing very bad code and like get
writing get to writing very good code
within a few environments
that I would believe.
that I believe
SF parties are so weird. I'm very glad
to not be an SF.
Trying to think what could what could
possibly be causing this to map
everything to 0.25. That's so weird,
right?
and then there's this gate.
No, the gate is this. Oh,
sigmoid and alert.
Does this just crunch everything to
0.25? I don't think so. Right.
Let me go read the site and come back
and extremely some questions. Yeah, it's
um those guides will link you to pretty
much everything. They're meant to be
worked through, not just read. Like the
programming and ML guide you can just
read. The other one is like a work
through this and it will take you
through the process of building some
environments.
You can do it pretty quickly. Like I
think spending a weekend on your first
environment or two is more than enough
time. It's if you try to do it in two
hours with LLMs, you're not going to
learn anything. But like a weekend is
more than enough time to actually learn
quite a bit of stuff.
Yeah, like I say, this stuff is not
simple, right? This is the hardest
branch of AI to get into. Um, the thing
is I've made it a lot easier and at
least you don't need massive comput
resources. But it's still hard. Like
there's a lot of engineering, but I've
kind of reduced to like if you can write
simple low-level code, you can write
useful environments. If you can write
usable environments, you can start
running experiments. If you can start
running experiments, you can start
testing hypotheses. You can do this very
quickly. And I kind of like drip feed
you the rest of the papers and things
that you'll need to read along the way.
It's not that many. Like if you read 10
total papers over the course of several
months, you will be in a very very good
spot.
Just pretty much exactly what the guides
say. Like I put a lot of work into
those.
Yeah.
Hey, I hope you enjoy. Welcome aboard.
We're always looking for new
contributors.
Most of the uh environment code at this
point is from contributors.
I think
let me try one thing. What if I just do
out
equals
state + one?
Can I just do this and see? I'm
basically just trying to figure out why
this is mapping everything to 0.25. 25
actually I know for sure this is not
expected because the uh non graph trace
version doesn't do this
more math focused in engineering not at
all I started actually having way more
respect for math than engineering when I
was like 16 or 17 and then it just was
repeatedly the case that engineering was
more useful to me than math so I'd say
that my toolkit now is 85% engineering
like 10% basic science 5% stumbling
through math.
You can watch my PhD uh defense online
and like you'll see that there's little
to no math in that talk.
It's not to say that math isn't useful,
but for what I was good at and for how I
think um I can make a much larger impact
with engineering than anything. Okay,
look at this. This gate is somehow
messing stuff up. It would seem
not as good at C and RL as per apps.
That's why I feel disconnected. That
just means it's dumb.
[clears throat] Like if you're saying,
"Oh, this is really good at doing like
routine basic tasks fast." That's
completely useless to me
because the thing is I can take I can
take any decent programmer and then get
them working on this stuff quite
quickly. You see what I mean?
But that's not what people are claiming,
right? People are not claiming, "Oh,
this is really good at doing basic
bullshit." People are claiming, "Oh,
this model feels, you know, so smart. I
can do 100 times more stuff. The future
is like whatever." Like, no. Building
like stupid standard crap 100x faster is
just like, man, right?
YouTube recommended your defense on my
feed. Yeah, it kind of blew up a little
bit, at least for a for a defense. It
was a good talk. I put a lot of work
into that. For context, I spent less
than a week writing my thesis document.
So that 170 page document, that's like
all my papers stapled together with a
intro, a conclusion, and a few little in
like sections in between. I spent a full
three weeks preparing my defense,
like the talk.
Yeah, Martin. But like now it's Carpathy
and other people, right? Like you know
uh Top Labs people saying this [ __ ] So
I think they're full of [ __ ] but I'm
going to give it a genuine try and I'm
not going to come back for another
couple generations if it's wrong.
Running post is really good. Thank you.
I'm not a gifted athlete. So, uh, stuff
like that is, you know, quite large of
an accomplishment for me.
I have a few fitness articles on there.
That's the only other content I will
allow myself to post once in a while
because um, you know, it's very, very
important to be in shape and a lot of
people in our line of work could afford
to do more of that.
I've got this awesome like ridiculous
bodybuilding gym uh, and powerlifting
gym in Florida.
And I'm going to be trying to put a
little bit of my lean muscle mass that I
lost uh back on in the next couple of
months.
Oh, wait, wait. Is this supposed to lurp
everything?
This doesn't make sense, right?
X context building pipeline image data
loader placed a list of tpples with a
dictionary order basic copies of your
random regressing curve. Agents need
memory.
The thing is they have the whole thing
in their context.
It's not just like, oh, they're bad when
you're out of context. They're bad even
when you have a relatively short
context.
How do you prevent yourself from LM too
much? Well, I don't have a smart LM. You
see this model? The model that's doing
my tab complete here is not cursor or
something. This is Super Maven. It's a
really stupid model. It's not capable of
writing like it's not capable of solving
any problems. It's basically a fuzzy LS
page. I really like this model because
it essentially it frees me to think
faster
um because I don't have to focus on
typing so much. If I typed 160 WPM and
if it were effortless to me, I wouldn't
use this model,
right?
But like this is super nice. It saves
typing, not thinking.
So, it's not like I don't use literally
anything.
Why don't I use a better model?
Well, I one, I don't want to rely on
something to think for me. I don't want
something that thinks for me. And two,
it's fast. You see how fast that is?
When as soon as I hit enter, it's
already there. I don't want the latency.
I don't want anything that interrupts me
when I'm thinking about stuff.
The thing is this goes through a linear
layer, right?
I don't really put too much stock in the
flow state thing
cuz like that's supposed to be when
something is not too easy or not too
hard. It's just as important when
something is really hard that you're not
interrupted, right?
or really easy that you can do it
faster.
I actually do think that there are forms
of um the current LLMs that like I would
find useful, but it looks very very
different from uh the way that people
are using them now and it's not worth it
to me to even bother like trying to set
that stuff up.
I'm sure you're not calling me old while
uh
you know
being absolutely mogged.
If you're gonna come here and like post
older, bro, you better post like a, you
know, powerlifting total by the way or
something.
more because you want to learn
something. Am I writing what you're
expecting?
What projects you want to work on?
Well, I mean the stuff I'm writing is
important, right? It's it's very
important to like understand each chunk
of this. So, this puffer thing I'm
working on is essentially an effort to
um this is going to reinvent the field
of reinforcement learning. In fact, it
already has like in two years I've made
RL a thousand times faster. This update
is going to make it about another 2x to
3x faster and then in important cases
it'll be like 10x faster yet again. And
those are not madeup numbers. like you
can actually check it. Um, and that is
legitimately what it is.
So, I like to work on stuff where if I
don't build it, nobody else will build
it. It has a huge potential for impact
on science and tech in general. Um, for
the last long amount of time it's been
RL. probably once I have RL in a good
spot from this which is actually going
to be within the next couple of years
I'll probably start going and looking
for areas of science that are highly
dependent on simulation and seeing what
we can do now with reinforcement
learning for those fields of science as
well as for some other like commercially
valuable problems
you know the profit is not the first
objective with what I do but it is the
second objective
What if I just set this to output?
Or can I just do hidden?
So yeah, Mera, for context, um, so
Puffer is kind of like a private lab.
All the stuff you see me working on
here, it's open source. We've got demos
on Puffer.ai. All our code's open
source, but then um, we also build high
performance simulations for companies.
That's the business side. There's a few
other things, but that's the main one at
the moment.
Simulation hypothesis, don't care. Nerd
snipe.
Okay, this is interesting.
Only it be about RL. No, not at all.
Yeah, not at all.
Generative is very important as well.
But like RL is very cool in the sense
that like the types of problems you
solve with small RL models are the types
of problems you just don't solve any
other way.
You get superhuman control instantly.
Why not go after those fields now rather
than rate wait because it'll be
dramatically easier with the RL like the
next gen of the tools that I'm building.
We are actually going off we are going
after a few other fields right now um on
the business side that are easier to do
with the tools that we have now and
essentially just harder problems get
easier uh every generation of puffer
like there's stuff that we are doing now
uh professionally with 3 that would have
been virtually impossible with puffer 2
and the same will happen with four and I
believe the same will happen with five
we already have plans for
Okay, so this is producing like a unique
output.
Can it not trace my custom kernels?
I'm so confused. Best way to contribute
just a new end. Well, if you're new and
don't have RL experience, it's the best
way to get started, right?
I wouldn't necessarily say just build an
M if you're already an experienced
system developer who has a ton of RL
experience, but if you just like have
some programming background and maybe
know some AI, like that's generally the
most accessible way to get started. And
there are people who have stuck around,
right? Built several Ms, like really
gotten a feel for this stuff, read some
papers, and who are now contributing to
our research side,
right? There's just there's this sort of
ladder of accessibility.
What does this mean?
You know what I want to try?
What if I try this? So, we don't use the
kernel. Does this also give us the 0.25
degen solution?
Oh,
what?
Um
guys,
that is this is what I say when there's
just like cursed undocumented errors.
I'm sure this wouldn't happen with just
native CUDA graphs either. This is like
Torch doing some weird stuff with it
tracing low-level code to network stacks
containerization and know nothing about
a IML ML. Well, I have good news for
you. Um it's harder to teach people the
system stuff than it is to teach people
the AI stuff. If you take a look on my
articles tab on X, I have my guide to
programming in ML. The ML stuff has just
decent advice for reading papers and
stuff, but what you're going to want is
the RL guide. It actually has like a
step-by-step walkthrough. And if you
have a systems back, it'll actually be
very, very easy. Like making a new end
will be I can make a new end in an hour,
like a basic end. So, it's definitely
the type of thing that if you have more
experience to uh in, you can work
through in like a a cozy evening and
then you can do something more
substantial in like a day or two, maybe
a weekend.
Like a lot of RL right now is just
bottlenecked by AI people not knowing
systems. Frankly,
I only started doing all this system
stuff two years ago. I wrote Python for
10 years and now uh two years later we
have the majority of the project written
in C
for Puffer 4. We're doing kernels. We're
doing all sorts of like all sorts of
stuff. Oh, that's so weird. Okay, so I
found the problem, guys. Look at this.
Uh these two things are tested to be
identical. Okay. But for whatever
reason,
for whatever reason, this one here, this
is not getting traced somehow.
I don't know how that's possible.
prompt engineer. Not at all, man.
What did I tell you? I use them for
fuzzy docs.
If there were a doc page from torch on
like cudggraphing requirements, I would
just be reading that instead. Right.
There isn't one.
Yep, that's the right one. shield and um
that's it's much more of like a work
through it type of a guide than it is
anything. You can read it once first if
you'd like, but it's kind of structured
like you know build this, read this
other thing, do this.
The idea is by the time you finish going
through that guide, you are like a very
qualified uh you're like you are very
qualified in RL.
But the first few sections of it will
have you build some sort of non-trivial
ends. Like if you can build a simple
arcade game basically that's high perf
and get an agent training on it quickly,
that's kind of the entry level for um
contributing.
If you can do that, you can already do
useful work though and that's on the
order of a few hundred lines of code
tops.
We do like our C around here. It's very
simple C.
Python bas do basic CAD?
Didn't uh doesn't Yasine have that?
I don't know, Nicholas. You're asking me
stuff way out of my area. Try it and see
if it works.
Learn by doing. I'd say 80% learn by
doing and 20 the other 20% you actually
have to do. Like you still have to read
some material, but most of your time
should be spent building stuff.
Are you gonna integrate Puff with
Unreal?
Not unless a client really wants me to
because like it's so slow, right?
You'd have to run like a thousand
distributed instances of Unreal to get a
reasonable amount of data.
Our environments
run like 10,000x real time.
Do you have to explicitly set the
stream?
Um, well, yes and no. You can still
train stuff at over 100,000 steps per
second on CPU. When you're doing
experiments, it's going to be much more
helpful to have a GPU of some variety.
You can rent a suitable GPU though on
VAS for like here. Watch this. These
aren't great because like sometimes they
downclock them and stuff, but like uh
here, this is 13 cents an hour. This is
30 cents an hour. So, if you want to be
able to train stuff, you don't actually
need a lot of compute, right? You don't
need H00s, you don't need H200's.
It will be helpful for you to have
access to some GPU. Um,
but you'll you'll be able to dev for
sure on CPU. You'll be able to test
basic stuff on CPU. It will be nice to
have a GPU when you're training stuff.
Oh, we actually repeat contributors get
access to our hardware as well. We have
a small cluster
or open code plus op is pretty useful
for tasks
where things are giant code bases. Yeah,
but that's like
I just don't have a code base like that,
right?
Like yes, LLMs are good good at like
helping you make sense of nonsense.
In my mind, I work very very hard to
avoid producing nonsense in the first
place.
I'm gonna try this just to see. I I'd be
surprised if this is actually the case.
That's what I'm saying. This is like
completely doable, right?
Is this really just going to put it on
some random stream?
Oh, right. Because the torch stream is
not the current CUDA stream
diffusion or transformer.
I think they're different.
I don't know enough about diffusion
models, frankly.
You know, we don't use either of those
in Puffer, right?
like it's a very different application,
pick up a textbook.
No, I b I had very basic systems intro
for my undergrad 10 years ago, right? So
like I know what memory allocation is. I
know what a pointer is, right? I know
what is a stack and a heap. And then I
just started writing some C.
That's pretty much it. And I wrote very
simple C.
And then it turned out, right, that I
could write about the same amount of C
as the code I had in Python, sometimes
less.
And it was very simple code. And things
are a thousand times faster. That was
the major discovery
for all of this sim stuff. Isn't that
funny?
That was the major discovery. I'm not
even joking.
Really? Wait, did is is this correct?
Did I am I seeing this correctly?
Are you serious?
You got to be joking, right?
course, it's not documented. They expect
you to be a complete and utter monkey
and not write your own kernels ever
and not manage any streams.
So, they just don't bother documenting
this crucial thing. Great.
Well, good job to GR for that given that
it's just not documented. This is
actually unfortunately one of the things
that I think we're going to have to use
LLMs for is um because LLMs exist, devs
just don't feel like they need to
document stuff anymore. Uh and there's
literally no way to figure this out
probably other than having read just all
of the code out there.
That's insane.
See, you know, I think the the type of
thing that I would really use often if I
could just stick this puffer fish that I
have here up in the corner and um say
like, "Hey, puffer, you know, what's
wrong with this?" Like, "Why is this uh
why is this one working but this one
isn't?" And it would go figure stuff
like that out. Just like having it be um
an encyclopedia of niche technical stuff
rather than trying to have it do things
for me. That would be awesome.
Why does some messages not make it?
Because there's a default filtering if
you either type too fast or put links or
whatever. I don't control that. It's
just whatever the platform does.
Template functions. I pass the function
dispatch
helper.
May do you if you have
Yeah. So, Eric, um I did this
intentionally because
do you have a way that does this that
doesn't have uh macros and stuff because
the way Torch does it? It does
everything with macros that eat all your
error messages, which is terrible. So,
this at least preserves error messages.
And I actually don't think we need to
support too many DTypes. I think it's
probably going to be uh one or two
Dtypes.
And you know depending it might just be
one D type and then there won't even
have to be any templating which would be
ideal
yeah, I guess the best form of this Jess
would be it could be more than that,
right? If you wanted something super
fancy, it would be you'd have something
that has an environment that would go
pick snippets out, tell you, I found
this snippet of the code here, actually
be able to point to it, write a test
example, and then isolate a bug. That
would be great because then you're not
handing over control to your repository,
right? You're basically just having it
like a uh search out these niche
technical things because I think I spend
half my time on average getting stuck on
these things at least for projects like
this where I have to deal with
cudigraphs. I have to deal with it
through torch. It's not documented. The
error messages are basically
non-existent,
right?
is getting the current stream slow. I
wonder
header file.
Well, this is Wait, is this not what
we're doing? This is I have this right
here, Eric. All right.
This one is like that. Some of this is
test code, right? So, this is um this is
not intended to be example of high
quality code. This is me messing around
with stuff, figuring out the way to
figure uh to do stuff to reasonable call
standards.
Like this is actually the first time
I've had to write these type of kernels
for uh like learnable operations.
The only other kernel I've had to write
before this update was the uh the
advantage kernel. And that's not like
that doesn't have to hook in the exact
same way
cuz it's not actually going to have to
be a learnable option.
Okay. The question is can we train now?
Right.
I do post these silly articles
occasionally.
Ry is also like not super big on um AI
code and Ray is probably one of the devs
I respect the most.
Like Ray Lib is just genuinely
it's such a good example of just a thing
that has been developed correctly and
the quality of the development of that
project and all the effort has put in is
what makes it such a useful toolkit.
Okay. So, why are we seeing zero score
here? Lovely.
I do some other weird stuff.
Yeah, no wonder. That's uh that'll break
it.
Left my test code in there.
So, so far we had,
you know, having to
reset the stream back to default as
major bug.
We had existence of other streams
starting during tracing as major bug
and then we've had
uh stream starting on other what is it
uh yeah kernel launching on wrong
stream. Okay so this produces at least
some learning signal. There's a whole
bunch of numerical checks because like
we're doing some jank stuff at the
moment. But as soon as I see non-trivial
learning, like this is good enough for
Perf tests. So
simple does not mean easy. Yeah, simple
does not mean easy.
Like by the time this is done, the
product of this is going to be so simple
that anybody who reads this and who has
not watched these streams is going to
like just assume I'm an idiot for
spending months on a relatively small
chunk of code that looks pretty simple.
But like you see why this takes forever,
right?
Like you see the types of problems I run
into
because nobody expects you to do this,
right? Nobody expects you to go
cudigraph trace the torch uh your torch
net in C++.
Okay, we have vec receive in here.
Is this already with
eight threads? It is. Okay, nice. So,
can we run profile on this?
So, that just got us over 7 million
steps per second
even with profile on chunks of it.
I'm trying to make sure We get all the
bugs.
We still have a ton of synchronizes. Oh
yeah, I added these in. Obviously, we
still have these full. I can fix that.
Uh,
still quite a bit of chronal launch
overhead.
Uh I have to look if these are now like
do these ops not include
well A10 mat mole is still in here.
The CUDA time though is low. I don't
know if this is now getting included.
Let's just um
let's cut out these extra synchronizes.
Like we don't need all these
synchronizes, right? And then let's see
what this does for us.
There's some copies we can still
optimize in here that'll get us maybe a
couple hundred thousand SPS.
But I think from here that majority
the rest of the tracing
this this profile this profile. Hang on.
We didn't want this. I wanted to run
train first.
7.4 4 mil.
Pretty good.
And now I want to see the uh number of
Fernal launches
or synchronizes.
check a couple messages because I am
responsible for
I don't know why I scroll. This is just
gross.
All right. So, here's what we have.
Uh, perfect. You see this? We just got
rid of most of the synchronized pulse.
So, we have
The kernel launches I believe is now
substantially lower,
but we still have a lot of them. You see
there 32,000 kernels here.
Let me go see what the uh the output of
this is.
They still appear.
All right. So, next we can Let's Well,
let's commit this first.
And I think it's going to be pretty easy
to trace the backward, right?
And actually, I'd like to go grab myself
um I'd like to go grab myself another
quick cup of tea.
before I start the next segment because
we fixed the evil evil bug. Took about
what that was an hour and a half. Yeah,
I've been live just under an hour and a
half.
Um, that wasn't that bad. And now what
we're going to do, uh, once I get my T,
we are going to,
uh, apply a graph trace to the backward
paths. And then I think ideally we're
going to have to trace the network uh
update step. Like I think we have to
trace the optimizer step.
I don't think that's a problem. I
actually think that's pretty
straightforward to do.
We shall see.
And then we'll see what happens with the
profile.
My hope I think if we can get to 8
million steps per second off of CUDA
optimizations
that's pretty nice because then I just
have to find an extra 25% overhead
somewhere and we'll be at the 10 mil
target. I'll be right back.
Yep.
Hey, Jess. Test CNS.
Welcome.
Okay,
next segment
we are going to do backward pass or not
backward pass backward um forward
backward whatever the training section.
So what we need to do Whoops.
What we need to do
stream meeting messages
fun. I can't do anything about that.
Do you graph the backwards? Actually,
this is something I can use the uh
the docs for, right?
either graphs.
I just want to see if they graph the dot
backwards.
Actually,
I can just look RL
and see what they do.
Where's the
Where's the graph in it?
where we celebrate is banned from
stream.
What does YouTube block you from saying?
Merry Christmas. Are you kidding me?
I think it's just eating random
messages.
Okay, put it put it in a sentence and
see if it blocks it.
That would be insane.
There you go. See? Okay. It's just it
being weird.
I was going to say
[clears throat]
>> All right.
Welcome, Elliot.
Okay, we're going to start with the
forward pass of this. Then
check Discord.
Hang on.
Yeah, that's weird. I don't know.
I mean, it's not blocking it for
everyone, so I assume it's just the
stream being janky.
What do you want me to do? Look, if
anybody has a better alternative to
reream
or like whatever that doesn't eat
messages, let me know.
But if it's getting eaten on YouTube,
like if you're not even seeing it in the
YouTube chat. Wait, are you seeing it in
the YouTube chat?
Hang on.
Let me see if it's
Oh, yeah. You're just posting a bunch of
messages.
Yeah. So, Reream is eating them. If
anybody has something better than
Reream, I will gladly use it. thought,
man,
I think it's just discriminating based
on the number of messages you send.
Frankly,
I'm pretty sure that's all it is.
All right, back to real work.
Can we pass a function?
Uh, yeah, we totally can. What's the C++
syntax for that?
C++ syntax pass. No
function
puffer pointer. Oh, it does have to take
one arc.
If like physics, can I work If I like
physics, can I work on this kind of
project? Yeah, there's plenty of
physics. I mean, we typically start with
lowfi uh or not lowi, low uh low
dimensional physics, not low fidelity,
but like here, this is physics based,
right? This is a drone environment. We
actually have some swarm environments.
We've got driving. This is arguably a
very simplified physics model, but
technically there is one.
Um here, this has a dodgy physics model.
I mean, technically anything is physics,
right? Like any of these things are
physics.
It's just the fidelity in like the thing
that you apply it to.
Boop.
Drone's probably best example.
not in college yet
in the final years of high school. We'll
learn, right? Like
my guides are pretty accessible.
Honestly, the hardest thing is just
getting the poor programming background.
I think I told you this yesterday unless
it was somebody else.
you will are you are going to eventually
need to get um like basic linear algebra
and multivari multivariable calculus at
least derivative calculus
the ideas are quite simple um the manual
calculation of derivatives is not super
super applicable you do do need to know
the idea the concept and like a few of
the things about this honestly the end
stuff is the hard frack the end stuff is
the hard are
very a very few people can just write
good simple fast code. And writing good
simple fast code lets you do basically
anything that you want.
And the problem is like there are hard
and fast rules for a lot of it, but a
lot of like some other pieces it's you
can't get hard and fast rules for.
Like it's object. It's pretty objective,
but it's also pretty hard to quantify if
that makes sense.
I will tell you I think that probably
high school was the hardest chunk of my
life. Um I will never work that hard
again. So things do get easier and
things do get more interesting as you
develop more skills. You are able to
work on things that are more interesting
and more directly useful.
At 15, I was like trying to figure out
how to knock together neural networks in
god awful mat lab or like python with
numpy. It was just such a mess.
I will be shocked if you learn to write
DC at 11.
Okay, so this still runs. So now we
actually have, you see this? We actually
have a relatively simple way to do this.
Um, let's do this like replay
I mean, this will end up being quite
easy then because we can basically run
the same code with or without graph
trace on
without having um to really make any big
sacrifices.
No, that still works. Look at that. 4
mil
forward. This just dies. Go away.
And Cool.
Where is
Where are my graphs?
Where my graphs at
right here.
Okay. So,
this is going to be train
eval graph. Let's train a valid graph.
Train forward graph
we're going to copy this function.
It's going to have to be basically the
same thing, right?
Uh and then this is going to be train
forward call.
And the actual logic that we need
uh the actual logic we need for this is
there's quite a bit that we could
technically graph.
Does an index select trigger a kernel
call?
I has to, right?
Do I need to learn C++ to get ready? I
wouldn't recommend it. C++ is really a
terrible language. Um, I'm only using it
right now because I have to because
Torch is written in a combination of C++
and Python, and I'm using the C++
interface. I need a low-level one. I
would be a much much happier man right
now if Torch were just written purely in
C.
C++. It's the reason it's a bad
language. It's just a whole bunch of
stuff like just bolted hodge podge onto
C.
Um, and it's just a very large language
as well. There are a million ways to do
everything.
Code size tends to blow up a lot and
it's actually kind of opaque what types
like what things you're doing are slow
or fast. So it's actually very easy to
end up writing slow C++ which then
defeats the point of even writing
low-level code.
My stack at the moment I am happy when I
get to write Python and C.
Actually less so happy about the Python.
Python's okay only when I'm doing stuff
that really isn't performance critical
in any way, shape or form. Um I'm
happiest when I get to write pure C.
There really only a few things that I
just, you know, are really clunky to do.
Uh, in C. There are a few things like
string processing is kind of a mess. Um,
Things are very simple, very easy,
and very fast.
Hey, hi Jai. Yeah,
your projects. Yeah, that's pretty much
what you do is right, you come up with a
simple project, you pick a new language
to do it with. That's fine. The thing is
you should not be hopping languages
constantly. This is in my guide as well.
Like there are very diminishing returns
on just picking up a dozen languages. It
teaches you a little bit about the
design, I suppose, but like you kind of
have to be doing a medium-sized project
and capable of doing that uh before
you're actually going to really see
whether the language is good or bad or
what the strengths or weaknesses are.
Like it it was really only a couple
years ago that I fully began to
appreciate the degree to which a
specific language can at the language
level force you to write code in a
particular way.
It's something that's easy to say but
it's like kind of difficult to
internalize.
fundamentals and syntax first. Yeah, but
that stuff is very easy.
Like most of the time when people have
trouble with syntax,
sometimes languages just have really
stupid syntax. But most of the time it's
because the syntax maps to a concept
that they don't understand.
Though in the case of languages like
C++, you know, sometimes it maps to a
concept that you don't need to
understand uh because it arguably should
not exist, right?
A lot of languages have stuff like this.
C flavor. Yeah, Eric. I just the things
that C++ gives you, I'm not even really
like there's nothing that I have here
from C++ that I wouldn't be super happy
to just give up in place of C, you know?
Like basically the only thing that's
kind of nice that you give up is being
able to call functions from like um
thing dot whatever instead of function
of thing, args.
I mean the things that I would actually
consider maybe wanting
stuff like named arguments maybe would
be nice. Um,
there's a lot of compiler level stuff
that I would like to be different, like
you know, things that should be errors
versus things that shouldn't, things
that should be default warnings versus
things that shouldn't.
But C is a very strong base.
The macro system kind of sucks, right?
But C is like a very strong base.
There are very few things that just
truly bother me about the language
function overloading too. I don't want
that one.
Honestly, it's kind of cool how Ray Lib
handles it.
Like Ray, they just there's like a base
function and then there's usually
there's an extended version and there's
like pro version. And they just they
have a few different ones that basically
cover all your use cases
and they're just very easy to stick in
the docs one line each.
I let me think would that even make
sense and see if you did optional args.
I guess I'll say I could see it right. I
could see it being okay. Yeah, I could
see that not being a bad addition to the
language, but I really don't miss it if
that makes sense.
Cuz actually there is a way to do that,
right? You just pass a strct and then
you just don't fill out the fields
train forward call.
This needs Yes. Right. So we need to do
graph train logics. Graph train new
values.
Yeah. So we'll do this one.
long range questions and follow
projects.
The thing is there's very little syntax
that you should need to learn in order
to do stuff, right? Like
because if you look at the way that I
write,
like if you're used to writing C, right,
you're used to doing a lot with very few
tools.
So if you're used to using very few
tools, there's very little that you need
to learn about a new language before you
can be effective.
You'll hit some rough edges. Like for
instance, um if you try to write fully
procedural code in Python, you'll kind
of see why it's a bit of a pain.
Hey Aaron, welcome.
So we have this one
badge.
How many hours?
Not including Sunday. It depends. It
varies dramatically, man.
Like, I can't even give you a good range
because it's anywhere from 30 to 90.
I would say a good week of work for me
is like 60 solid hours. I can get a lot
done with 60 focused hours.
70 is better. 70 is tough.
It's not a crazy number of hours though.
Like I've done way way way more hours
before.
The bottleneck is mostly the clarity and
the focus
and like not wasting time on dumb [ __ ]
I don't know. I grew up doing 110 for
school. So, and then like 90 for
college,
which is funny because now you know the
70 actually 70 feels very hard to do. 70
hours of focused work on something like
this feels very different from like 70
hours where you can kind of turn your
brain off half the time.
12 a day.
Well, I mean 12* 6,
right?
I'm going to be trying something
slightly different actually while I'm in
Florida, which is I'm going to try to
have more days that are fully devoted to
work and then I'm going to have some
days that are what more split. So like I
do a short block, maybe 3 to four hours
in the morning and then I go to the gym
for at least two hours. I'll probably be
out for 3 hours in the middle of the day
between gym and lunch and then I come
back for another 3 to four hours. So,
I'm going to try that instead for a
little bit and see if I like that more.
Florida beaches. Beaches aren't really
fun for me.
rest hours.
Yeah, that's what I do.
I'm pretty fresh now, though.
I just got back from vacation.
All right. So, we have this. We have
this.
This one's supposed to be
Oh, that's train.
This looks good.
Well, Aaron, we have I mean, we have
already we're do we have some commercial
impact already. Like, we've got a few
clients now. Um,
I think
40 should put us to the point where like
anybody can just run this stuff on their
laptops.
This should really really lower the
compute barrier to entry.
Um,
I think that we'll have it by 40 or
slightly after we'll have it to the
point where the arcade level tasks
pretty much are full automated. like you
can solve anything that looks like of
that complexity
pretty much automatically.
I think within the next year after that
we'll get to solving the medium level
tasks pretty much automatically. You
know, basically the environments right
now that qualify you to be a
professional uh contributor, right? Like
to work on contracts, so actually
commercially valuable stuff. we'll start
to have that level of stuff fully
automated
um solving it, not building the sim
obviously. And then we'll be able to
like you know use our tools not fully
automated but with high confidence to
take on some very hard problems.
So the timelines are only like a year or
two max out now.
It ultimately it really a lot of it just
depends on how much focused work I can
get out of myself and what other
roadblocks we run into.
Like this stuff is hard. You see the
type of things I have to fight here.
Uh, low dim robotics, Melanie. Right
now, lowdimensional robotics. So, like
drones are considered low dim robotics.
Not a ton of degrees of freedom. You
don't need a super heavy sim.
We could there are a number of areas of
robotics that we could go into
productively right now. And it's mostly
just a matter of clients, right?
So, we don't tend to we don't really
tend to go try to like build a fancy sim
for three months and then go sell it.
Like the professional side is much more
we build all these tools and then people
come to us for general RL and then we
build sims based on that.
I'm on a tea kick for the time being
though. had too much damn caffeine
lately.
All right, let me get a bit of this
stuff done. So,
yeah. So, this one here, this needs to
be
And then what we can do is pop our graph
train logs
And then state state matter. I don't
think state matters.
I think we're good.
Okay. So, this is our train forward
call,
right? Train forward call.
So now what we can do is we can put this
can just do train forward fault on puff.
And then if we just do
don't think these modify in place I
think this is totally fine.
So, this is not traced
yet. Just going to make sure we haven't
broken it.
bring forward. Oh yeah, this because
this have to get defined way higher up,
right?
Is this it forward call?
Yeah, we'll do like this. Train forward
call.
good.
And hopefully this is just easily
traceable.
Not convert.
match.
Did our stack tra this
Let's not do the capture then. Let's do
this first.
Um something
batch
Okay, cool. So, we have an execution
error.
Make sure we're good there.
I have a
I'm trying to help somebody with a catch
a flight and um
the weather is not cooperating.
Not loser. Nope.
Actually, this is probably the last day
I'll have this. This was a temporary
$100 phone. So, it's kind of funny. If
you look at this, the three cameras on
this thing is what you get for a $100
phone these days.
Uh, the easiest way to do this is to
just like
I have it set up so that when I SSH in,
it just boots me right into um a
container as well.
It's not like SSH to the container. It's
just that the uh the setup script does
it.
It's all pretty light.
uh these look like the correct sizes to
me, right?
Five
one 128. This is the correct H.
What' I mess up?
Oh, the copy probably, right?
I bet you it's the copy.
New value sizes.
Oh, I know what it is.
Bet you it's this.
have to do
up forel.
You got to do both of these.
It's basically the same um same thing.
You have to trace the net twice though
uh if you have different shapes.
So the idea is you always have the same
shape at train and the same shape at
roll out. Face it twice.
Kind of backward through a graph the
second time. Oh, you know why? I know
what this is.
I think that this will work if I put
this here.
I think
because I can do
yeah if I put this here I think this
works
and this will take another bite out of
the um food launch overhead. Hopefully.
wait. We're not even tracing this yet
though, right?
Yeah. Yeah, we're not even tracing this.
So, because this is train
forward fall
Oh, yeah. This one. No, this copy
underscore
Does copy underscore not preserve brats?
Oh, I guess it doesn't.
That seems weird, right?
Okay. So, if this does preserve,
I guess with training there's
it's what's the the fuse scan kernel?
Oh, you dummy. You forgot this. How did
I forget both of these? Well, that'll do
it.
This one
launch used forward.
So, this is the same bug from before. We
already fixed this.
It's um it's launching on a different
stream, so it's not capturing gradients
correctly is my guess.
Um, I took it was Carpathy. I don't know
if Carpathy was still It was Justin, I
believe, was teaching it.
Justin's lectures are very good.
He gets a lot of subtle things correct
that like most would just skim over.
Okay, now I'm confused.
I just fixed the kernels
launch. confused.
Yeah,
just getting the current stream right
to the launch.
So, what we're calling
brain forward,
you're copying the OBS and state
in
And then you're getting train logic
train new value.
But then these get copied. Train logic.
Yeah, these get copied in.
This is supposed to preserve gradients
as well.
So this op definitely has gradients.
Be really nice if we could figure out
where
MB state is here.
MB ops is here.
These get copied in
train forward. It's not even tracing
yet.
Logic's new values. It should be fine.
Should be fine.
Just I want to see if I just do it this
way real quick.
I think it's this right.
That's
are saying that this actually does is
supposed to work.
Here's the restroom real quick. I'll be
back in a minute.
Do I have to mark these as required?
Brad,
And then I'm going to restore this
signature like this.
So I'm going to see if marking the
outputs is requiring gradients gets the
copy correct.
Torch is very implicit sometimes. It's
kind of annoying.
A variable that requires rad is being
used in an in place operation.
There's got to be a way to do this,
right? This like this should be
standard.
Um
I don't know how much has changed.
Probably the newer versions have
transformers and stuff.
I mean ML fundamentals are really like
autograd supervised learning train
loops. Like it's
what's a con, what's a maple? water like
various things. It's a lot of it is very
much the same.
I honestly I think the hardest part is
just developing sufficient engineering
maturity.
Yeah. Seeing latest bit. Oh yeah. Yeah.
The interview
that was fun.
Snake style CNN.
Oh, wait. This is just hang on. Got any
suggestions?
Most used ResNet.
Snake style CNN.
You're probably
if you're doing one hot embeddings right
now,
can that just be flat?
It's like a couple thousand, isn't it?
If it's flat. So, try a flat net for
comparison.
Um,
you can try like a couple deeper stacks.
CNN's get slow very quickly though.
In my mind, the goal is going to be
going forward that we spend less effort
scaling the encoders, right? Like the
encoder should just the goal of that
should just be to get it into some
reasonable hidden dim. They don't
actually have to be powerful
and then most of the work is going to
come from the main network
because we actually have an architecture
that stacks nicely. And Justin, what I'm
going to do, I think I unless I come up
with something better, I'm going to give
it the best possible chance of working.
So, I'm going to have an environment in
mind that I think I could write in a few
days that will be roughly a thousand
lines of code. So, standalone, doesn't
depend on anything, very simple
interface to interact with other stuff,
but like doesn't have to use anything
else directly.
um only uses one very common dependency,
nothing else,
tons of example code.
So like really really good case for
Opus, right? And I think it's going to
just fail catastrophically.
takeaways from Tiny Bread. I like what I
see so far. Um,
so I think I need to do more looking
into it. I think that there's going to
be a way that I can use their kernel
gem. I'm taking a break from that now
because I have some other optimizations
independent from kernels uh for Puffer
that I need to get done first.
Uh I I wish it were not written in pure
Python,
you know. I wish I think tiny in C would
be awesome. Um right now it doesn't give
me enough low-level control and it
really seems like they kind of expect
nobody to want to manually write kernels
or like manually interface at that
level. And
like that would be okay if they
magically had crazy high performance,
right? But the thing is most of the time
they they're like matching Torch's eager
mode when you turn on all their
compilation options. Sometimes they're
faster, sometimes they're slower.
So like it seems to me that
we still need lower level interfaces.
That has not been disproven. It seems
unlikely to be disproven.
And I think it's way better than Jax at
least like if you're going to have a
pure Python library. Um, Tiny is very
good for that. They will continue to get
more performance optimizations over time
to be more competitive with Torch and
other things. Um, it's a much smaller
project with a lot less jank, which is
nice, but I really would like more lower
level interfaces. And then there just a
few missing things as well. A few
missing things. I am going to spend more
time with it. I told George I'd spend
more time with it. Um, but I need to
finish some of this stuff first.
Like also their source code is very nice
and succinct. I kind of view the golf
thing they do as just a quirky style
thing, you know, like their code isn't
bad in the sense that I can literally
take the same code and just add some
white space and it's fine or like, you
know, put the double nested loops or
whatever compressions into two lines,
like basic stuff like that. But the
actual so what I've seen so far, the
actual control flow is fine.
The style is just kind of quirky.
This is like some weird graph
shenanigans.
RGI
very little. It's like it's kind of
interactive, but the interaction portion
of the problem is trivial. So,
it's still it's like it's still mostly
pattern recognition and then a tiny bit
of interactivity.
Good job giving me completely wrong
answers, Brock. See, this is what I mean
by say like these models are just
terrible.
Like this is just bad.
Actually, let me try this. I might
actually be wrong here. Let me check
real quick. I don't think so.
I might be wrong here. Let me double
check.
I don't see how that would work, though.
cuz like what's it do? Forward
rain.
Yeah, I've already um I already said I'm
going to do a stream with Opus.
I'm not going to interrupt my work now
to go [ __ ] with other models,
especially when it's literally just the
labs leaprogging each other every couple
months. And I've had people telling me
this every couple months for the last
year, like two years even. The only
reason I'm even doing this is because
Car Pathy tweeted it.
This is what it told me to do, right?
Yeah, like this. This exact thing.
Yeah, exactly. See, it's stupid. I tell
you, it's stupid. That's like a basic
That is a super basic thing. That's like
a four-line bug. I gave it full context
and it's just wrong.
And I'm supposed to expect that these
models are superhuman. Like they're
crap,
Okay. So here we have this. This works
now. Now can we trace the graph?
train for graph
length
But like the thing is the stuff it knows
is usually stuff I also know.
If the things can't generate anything
new, then what the [ __ ] am I using them
for, right?
That's not even something new, though.
That's like literally
I mean that's just a hard fail is what
that is.
That's just like fundamentally not
understanding what a graph is.
Yeah, exactly, Jess. It seems
architectural to me at this point, you
know,
like by 3.5 it was kind of like, okay,
what's going to be emergent versus what
isn't? And now several generations
later, we have way better models, but we
have a lot of the same failure
modalities that we had two years ago or
three, whatever it was. not that long in
time, but it's a lot in terms of money
poured in.
And uh
it doesn't seem like they're getting
qualitatively
like qualitatively different like
they're doing more of the same but
better.
Yeah, Ilia is very good.
I watched his um his interview on
stream. His interview is very good.
Did I post that as a video? I should
have if I didn't.
A four run-of-the-mill stuff doesn't cut
it, though.
But it's like, you know, people, oh,
you're so behind if you're not using the
latest agentic, whatever the [ __ ] It's
like, oh, but it only works for
run-of-the-mill stuff when it fails.
Well, like,
so you're behind because you're not
using the model that does
run-of-the-mill stuff
because you're assuming that you're just
doing like, huh?
Right.
Good engineers are not going to be doing
the run-of-the-mill stuff most of the
time anyways. And they're pretty darn
quick at it when they are. Like when I'm
doing basic stuff, I dev pretty fast.
I mean the thing that I would like which
should be possible and like kind of
works but is generally pretty bad and is
not at all validated and is hallucinated
more than half the time is like these
things have read just about every public
piece of code. So things that are not in
the docs that are like niche bugs that
somebody has written a comment for in
their repository above like the one line
that's very hard to find on Google. Like
that's stuff that would be valuable,
right?
Cuz that's where I waste half my time.
And that's honestly the thing that like
burns me out a ton is just having to
waste time and effort like tracking
stupid bugs because it's so boring and
so obnoxious.
You can do that with like not AI though.
You don't need AI for that.
But like that is not
that's like a very marginal thing, you
see?
Like I don't spend most of my time doing
that. That's a super marginal thing.
Um, so I didn't attend Nurex. I ended up
being there for one evening and I went
to one dinner because I I randomly I had
a layover on the way to Hawaii. So there
might be a picture or two of me, but I
didn't actually go to the conference.
Okay. So,
what is wrong with this then?
It's much faster.
I think we have to do zero grad as well,
right? Where's the optimizer?
you were there. Yeah. So that's why um
and I wasn't actually even going to go
to anything.
The reason I don't go to the big
conference is because I got pneumonia
there last year and it nearly killed me.
So, I kind of just said screw that this
year. Um,
I got the only reason I even went to a
dinner is because I went to check in at
the hotel. It just happened to be the
same hotel as the conference hotel cuz
it was the nearest good hotel to the
airport and I happened to run into my
main collaborator like just immediately
on getting to registration.
It was like a a small world kind of a
thing.
How much did you spend in your
warehouse?
I'll tell you the um
the gym equipment wasn't bad. I'll tell
you the
uh the PCs were what is it?
It's like 10 desktops, I think, plus two
tiny box. Two tiny boxes.
It's probably between 80 and 110,000.
Savings or contribute.
Um, I mean I initially was buying stuff
off of savings, but like um Puffer has
more than paid for them by now. So like
the initial ones were uh the initial
ones were bought off of like the initial
money that I put into the company and
then we started making money and now
we're buying new new machines off of
profits.
Are you working on any new papers
though? I work on releases and blog
posts. I don't really do papers.
I don't really publish anymore. It's not
worth my time. I don't get that much out
of publishing. The peer review process
is an actual joke at this point. And I
actually get more exposure and less time
out of just writing a a good blog post
on my release than I do from a actual
published paper. And without a like a
six to eight month lag time for review
as well.
So, I don't know. Maybe once in a while
I'll submit something if it's easy, but
there's really not much reason for me to
be writing papers anymore.
Favorite puffer ends I've worked on.
Let me see.
I have to look at completed ends that
I've personally worked on.
I mean, I assume that you don't count
just like adding a little binding fork
because slime ball was cool.
I guess like snake was the first one,
but it's kind of dated.
I think Nurmo is just far and away the
best one.
I mean, I've like I've made smaller
contributions to a lot of these.
Probably that doesn't count.
This one is surprisingly fun. Like these
types of Ms. They're just like this.
This is super simple and easy and you
can scale it up very nicely.
This is basically a scaled version of
that with some extras.
This is kind of cool, right?
Okay. Why is this broken?
Why is this broken?
Yeah. See, this isn't what we need
either.
They're capturing the entire thing.
Is that better?
Thinker professional.
What makes a useful M
do 231N?
Um
I mean it's mainly clients come to us
asking for things, right? Like we've
done stuff in finance and commerce. We
have some stuff planned for the new year
in gaming. Um we have what else?
We've done some like defense adjacent
type stuff
earlier before that we did some
animation things. There's a lot of
different sims, right? Like simulation
is just very broad.
It tends to be fiddly problems where
there isn't a good way to do it without
RL and we can build fast sims.
approaching financial stuff.
I mean, I don't have a finance
background, right? I have an RL
background. So, in my mind, finance is
just it's like one additional
application, right?
And companies are not working with us
because I'm a financial guru.
That makes sense.
I know. I've had a lot of people who
like think that their problem is
uniquely challenging and then it turns
out to be about as difficult to learn as
Breakout.
RL's really, really good at fiddly
little optimization problems.
Yeah, it is cool.
I mean, look, I it's pretty simple now.
If you tried to do this stuff before
puffer li, you'd be screwed, right? like
you get two to three,000 steps per
second training and that's just GG.
So, it's kind of because of the last two
years worth of work and all the research
that went in before that over my PhD
that we're now able to do this.
So, it's not like this is just simple,
right? We've made like we've worked hard
to make it simple.
GitHub stars go up
buffer. big.
I know exactly who that is. How's it
going, Charlie?
I remember that username.
Or she I got I got some of my own now.
It's got to be something with trace,
right?
Hang on. I have an idea. What if I don't
replay?
Let me make sure I'm not breaking it in
the process of tracing it first.
>> Oh yeah, I think I owe you steak dinner
the next time uh the next time I see
you. You had some good advice.
any good domain that you might suggest
would be good for a paper in 2026.
Uh there are a lot but it really depends
on your experience.
Like exploration is a big one but the
thing is there have been a ton of papers
on exploration and pretty much everybody
frames it wrong.
So
yeah,
we have some plans for that in puffer
five. I got to get puffer four done
first.
Yeah, the scoping thing, man. The
scoping thing helped for sure.
That's the main piece I use so far.
We've been doing quite well lately.
Honestly, the the thing like the main
worry at the moment is just the pure
technicals.
I get running shoes for 500 Navy Seals
workouts.
I get um Brooks Adrenalized I think
Brooks Adrenaline or Adrenaline, one of
those. That's what I use. They're pretty
good. I'm not really doing a super heavy
running block at the moment. So before I
left, um
I put a like five pounds back on, but a
lot of strength uh back on after the cut
over the summer. So before I left, uh
before I left Maryland, I pulled 405 raw
and I ran a couple of well, a couple
different times. I ran a 634ish mile,
decentish 5k times. I haven't done um I
haven't done distance in a bit, though.
So, distance is going to be a few weeks
of training to get back into. I'm not
going to do that over this until over
the summer, though. I'm trying to put a
little bit of weight back on while I'm
in Florida since I have um this
ridiculous gym 10 minutes away.
Well, I'm not breaking it with um I'm
not breaking it with the graph capture.
So, it's literally just somehow
replaying this graph.
This doesn't work.
How would you frame it since you're not
writing papers?
That's not what I mean, Jess. Not like
to get it accepted. I mean to be valid.
Element zero of tensors does not require
bread and does not have a grad function.
Was like we capture
We craft your train forward graph
with train forward call.
Right.
Still curious.
It's a longer conversation and it's
going to be something I really dig into
in Puffer 5. I basically
I think that they're just they're two
different parts of exploration. One of
which is actually probably solved
implicitly and one of which has not been
isolated correctly before.
this is weird. Element zero of tensors
does not require Brad.
Are you not supposed to trace the
forward pass independently like this?
I mean, what happens if I Hang on. I
have an idea.
If I just trace the backward pass,
right?
Well, if I do this and I just decide,
you know what? You're going in train.
You're going in here,
right?
Value. And I'm gonna have to pass a
bunch of crap to this, I think.
Comput is a very big thing here. But
it's not.
Comput is a big thing because
everybody's writing slow code.
We're not computebound at all. We're
like skill capped because everybody's
written stupid slow code.
Like the stuff I'm doing now is
optimization after I've already made
things a thousand times faster. And so
you don't even have to do this level of
stuff.
Um, in fact, there was so much free perf
you could have made it 10x faster than
everything was before without even
really trying and nobody did.
That's not true. A couple people tried a
few things to make it 10x faster, but
then they overco complicated it. You
really don't have to work that hard to
make stuff 10x faster.
Yeah,
it's kind of GG.
So, I just take this and I put
everything from this into puffer rail.
I think that's it, right?
And then I don't have to worry about
these output buffers being straight
We also need need to add some scrap to
this
which is going to be
needed all this stuff right
mean that's so annoying though because I
have to pass this.
Yeah. So, everybody's been bugging me
about this, man. I said I'm going to do
a stream because of Carpathy. I do not
believe this [ __ ]
You can build a company in 10k lines,
man. A really good one, actually. Hell,
you can fix 10 good 10,000 good lines of
code. like you can fix a lot of really
major outstanding problems with that.
Like I genuinely think for this use case
I could probably replace torch in 10,000
lines.
smaller than 10 kilos. So I have a
project. I came up with a basic project
that would take me a few days that I
think can be done in about a thousand
lines. Um that I'm expecting Well, I was
going to try Opus 4.5, right? That's in
plug code. Yeah,
cuz that's what everybody's telling me.
And um if it's good, hey, yay, I'm
wrong. I will like consider how I can
use the new tools. I'm going to be
shocked if it is.
It may speed you up. I can't explain it
in English. It like the other models at
the least are wrong.
I mean they get stuff wrong all the time
on the level of like you know individual
line just wrong usage of stuff and not
understanding how libraries work.
So like they actually in my case they
fail at even being good fuzzy docks.
At least Sonnet and Brock 41 both fail
at even being fuzzy docks half the time
for what I'm doing.
So we will see. I will stream the whole
thing with 1K lines. I'll announce it as
well at least a day in advance so that
people can come tell me, "Oh, you're
doing it wrong or whatever. You're not
prompting the language model correctly."
because I want it to be like unambiguous
one way or the other,
right? I want it to be like completely
unambiguous
that like I gave it a project where it
should totally be able to work.
Get stash if it messes up.
Okay.
like the standard is is this better than
me just writing the code myself right
that's the bar
and by myself I get to include at this
point my current workflow which includes
a really really stupid model that's fast
that saves me mostly typing. Like this
model here is I don't even know. It's
super maven, right? It's probably like
less than 3.5 level of a model. I don't
know. Um and then there's
I use um I try to use models for fuzzy
docs occasionally when they don't exist.
I don't really use them to write chunks
of code.
yeah so um Charlie I I plan on I have
it's a thousand line environment. I have
several environments worth of sample
code. I have the entire puffer repo, but
like it doesn't need to use any of that
stuff. So, it's very self-contained. The
only dependency is for the graphics,
which will be ray, which is a very well
doumented and widely used project.
So, it should be the perfect use case.
I'm expecting it to flop terribly.
We shall see.
is cloud code is it supposed to actually
be able to like compile and run your
project uh to debug stuff or no?
Or is it only do that in Python? like
cuz I'm assuming at the very least if it
doesn't do that there's just no chance
so it has to at least it would have to
be at least compiling and checking the
output of C
the agents can be you need to whitelist
the commands I see
yeah see you man
rap visdoom yeah visdoom works oh um
there There's uh there's a very low
resolution option in Vizdoom that if you
turn it on, you'll get even faster.
Okay, I will make sure I let it do that
then
to accidentally arm dash RF your
computer. Yeah, I've heard it likes to
do that.
Copy return. Okay, so this should be
fine, right? So everything is copied in
8 m.
I think you can get up to like between
100 and 250,000 on Doom.
Uh it's there is actually a really old
like janky Visdoom binding in Puffer. If
you look there's a comment that tells
you where it is. Like it's a niche thing
that I had to find in the source code. I
there's like basically a potato
resolution and it saves you a lot. Um,
that's what you want to do.
Use cursor, not cloud code. Yeah. But
can we agree that like
if I if I do this experiment with like
claw code and opus or whatever like am I
still going to get people saying oh you
should have used my favorite model
instead
because at that point I think that
people are just imbeciles right like oh
yeah we get to split hairs over like
which of these models
like you didn't use the model that came
out last week
it's like well but you say you've been
saying that this stuff is good for the
last two years so like
you know
Like if you're specific to the boiler
plate. Well, exactly. But this is the
thing, right? Like look. So that guy,
this is not what I'm talking about,
okay?
I'm talking about this [ __ ]
Like my whole feed has been
this [ __ ] tweet. And people like, "Oh
yeah, like if you're not using these for
your code, you're trolling."
That's not like, oh, it writes a bit of
boilerplate, right?
I guess if you spend all your time
writing boilerplate, then yeah, it makes
you way faster, but then you're just an
Nimbusil.
So, right, like this is a very, very
clear thing that it's saying, and it's
not, oh, they're good for boilerplate.
And my whole feed is like imbecile
retweeting this.
I know the people retweeting him
imbeciles. We'll see whether or not um
this has any merit. I will be shocked.
I will honestly be shocked. I'm setting
aside a day in the next I don't know
sometime after I finish cudigraphs to do
it.
I think it's mostly just lazy people who
previously had no skills um who are just
like happy that they now feel validated
because they can type stuff in and the
model tells them how smart they are and
produces like some junk,
right?
and then like a few smarter people
who've kind of gotten hoodwinkedked into
this stuff.
That is my expectation.
Why would you have to say exactly Jess?
Like that's the that's the only reason
I'm going to bother because I wrote a
thing like hey if somebody credible
tells me to do this I will. Nobody
credible replied uh in the affirmative
and then Carpathy later went and wrote
this thing. So
Cool. So, we got to fix this. Let me use
the restroom real quick. Um, I'll be
back.
I missed the 300k lines code comment.
The thing is I don't need 300,000 lines
of code.
Like
I can solve so many things with 30,000
lines of code or even 10.
I mean, there are real problems that you
can solve in a thousand lines of code,
right?
Like most 300,000 line code bases are
that length because the developers suck.
Obviously, there are some real projects
that actually need to be long, but I
would say that most super big repos are
just that big because the developers
suck.
It's like completely possible to write
10 times more code than you need or even
more.
It's completely possible to write code
that's a thousand times slower than it
should be or even more. Happens all the
time,
right? So, what's this? So, we have this
is the
needs and state.
Why do you use layer norm? Because we
tested it and it worked. I don't like
it, Jess. Um, this model here actually
is going to need an RMS norm to be good
and I need to find a replacement for
that because RMS norm is really slow.
This is something I need to study. If
anybody wants to go study it, that would
be great. It's like um small to
mediumsiz science project. I would say
science side project pure experimental.
It seems to be very necessary for uh
this model specifically because this one
gets stacked deeper
Where's this?
Oh, I did this dumb. Hang on.
Let me just print all the sizes.
Come on. Let's get this thing done.
screws up in coding goes up anyways.
Yep.
RL is very good. A lot of the times I
can't figure stuff out.
Oh, this compiled. No.
What are we breaking on? Oh, we're
breaking on the capture.
Where is it?
Oh,
we did it.
Okay, so we got logits.
Oh, wait. Advantages is
Yeah. And then trial is just this
Good.
So, um,
that should be fine.
I should print the D types to be sure,
right?
I've never liked tensor board.
I think it's going to be want to be in
constellation in our next update.
Constellation's our new thing.
It's quite cool.
You'll get to see the dev on stream for
that in a few weeks most likely.
I don't think any of this is
lightweight, man.
It's why I made constellation. It's like
a different thing. But constellation is
not for live. monitoring at the moment.
It's for aggregate monitoring.
Okay, this one runs.
Six.
now I want to capture.
Oops. Let's duplicate graph capture
first. Let's not get ahead.
That's like incredibly obnoxious.
That is incredibly obnoxious. Holy
because this a capture.
Um,
can we replay?
Oh, it's not train. Hang on.
Okay, I'll deal with that in a second.
Let me see if this even runs.
well, hello there.
That would be perf target. If that
number is real,
if that number is real, we win.
And I don't have to do any further
optimization. I will just have to clean
everything up.
I mean, I'm obviously going to go by
bother like doing it with the the
optimizer as well, just cuz it's
probably an extra little bit of perf,
but um the goal for this release is 10
mil.
That would be amazing.
I'd be so happy.
I didn't expect it to do that much. I'm
a little suspicious that it might just
not actually be calling fan shop,
but you would get more perf back if it
weren't calling yet.
Interesting.
We got to figure out what happened here.
This is breaking.
Okay. So, this one here, look, got our
OB, we got our state,
we got our actions, log, project,
managers, priorities, values, and
returns.
Those all look good, right? We have
everything that we would want there.
Graph train
state.
We get MB OBS
state
obs. MB state
C project with PI bindings.
Um,
we have something sort of. So, Eric,
you're going to really like
constellation.
I don't think we have screenshots around
but you can go look in for 40.
It's a single file
uh ray for rendering dashboard that will
handle you know many thousands or tens
of thousands of experiments worth of
data and do everything in aggregate with
like a whole bunch of different plotting
options that is instantly responsive
with no lag
and will be runnable in your browser as
well.
I don't have live anything in it, so I
don't have live monitoring, but it'll be
very nice.
We're not going to count our 10 bell
until we actually see it. Train.
Are we still replaying?
No, we're not replaying that, right?
No. Okay.
I mean, that's like How did I break
this, right?
we do
the ops to d type state
going to produce new value logits.
test.
We give it
actions
log props
Yeah, because it doesn't write. So
that's fine.
File value returns
deviation.
That seems fine to me, right?
That's weird.
That is weird.
What could have gone messed up?
These states supposed to be zeroed.
Okay, so this is still broke.
Okay, so now we start getting confused
and concerned
because
now. Yeah. Now the question is, did I
mess something up? Actually,
let's just make sure capture
is not
I want to make sure this is not screwing
us up somehow stupidly.
Ah,
see this is why we check things.
There we go.
Just not zeroing the grabs.
Okay.
Let's
Well, let's not yet graph replay, I
think. Right. We do this first.
Let's make sure the copy version works.
But look, it doesn't it doesn't
optimize.
But I don't think that this was running.
So I actually
Yeah, this is probably not going to be
as fast.
I do
failed.
Man, that's so annoying that that
happens.
This doesn't fix the um
this actually this compiled.
Can't think of anything else that it
would use, right?
It doesn't optimize
at all
I'm going to try something. I don't I
know if this makes sense,
but I think technically right.
It's still not
It's still not um
not doing anything.
We can capture the graph.
Let's
see.
There is a torch tutorial, right?
This is already true.
I don't think this does anything.
Let's make sure that we actually have
it.
Uh,
it should be here within the next couple
days. I know it's been forever, but
yeah, that's the situation.
cuz I got shipped to the barn
and uh I got there while I was on
vacation. So now it's going here.
Okay. So see what they're doing on this
weird
take that input test.
Oh, I could see that screwing it up,
right?
I think this actually might be it,
we play versus just train forward calls
the same thing.
It's a fuse scan as well, right?
Log codes and values, fuse scan.
Quite a lot of things actually get used
in here.
let's just let's get a full a full
assessment of this without the custom
kernels.
Ah, what we need to do.
All right.
We're very close. As soon as we have
this working, I think we should see
quite a good PF improvement. And I think
like this will take us to the finish
line even already.
This might end up letting us overshoot
our Perf target for the update.
Well, I guess we have the RMS norm thing
to still figure out.
Love your thoughts on any of the mess
helpful
uniform and omelet.
That's cool. Yeah, I'd like to look at
that.
How could I learn to program? What
resources could I learn with?
The stuff around here is much more
accessible than you'd find elsewhere for
what I'm doing. It's still not super
beginner friendly, but all of my best
advice for programming, it might be a
little early for you if you're new. Um,
all my best advice is on my ex
Jarvis 5341
and uh this article right here,
biggest classes of Perf games.
The large batch formulation is a decent
chunk of it. Um
the environment speed, the vectorzation
speed. Um there is now with the new
version, right? Eliminating Python
overhead, custom kernels,
um CUDA graphs or launch overhead
reduction,
tons of asynchronous copies. It's like
they're just a ton of them. And it's the
problem is that you kind of get a flat
profile.
Like it just everything is slow in the
normal libraries. It's not like there's
just a few things I can improve. Every
single thing needs to be rewritten and
tossed out.
No,
just has some of our optimizations but
not a lot.
You see it's much slower, right? 4.8
mil.
Now this one
at least we have no custom kernels in
this.
Um my article I would use it more as a
reference point. Like
just save that article and read it every
so often while you're learning to
program.
It just has all of my best advice for
like not wasting a ton of time.
Programming is a very barely a very very
poorly taught subject.
And if you're taught it wrong, it takes
a very long time to unlearn and relearn
the correct way.
So this is it's not the custom kernels
breaking this somehow.
that would be a good one to print the
first weight.
I mean, my advice is kind of in there,
right, for that. It's you need some
amount of formal resources from a
course. I don't really know any great
ones for beginners. I mean, I haven't
been that in a long time. Um, but like
the course material,
it's not going to teach you how to
program well. Like it's there to teach
you syntax mechanics
when you get to lower level details of
how an operating system works that at
least are directly relevant.
Memory management.
The point of the courses is to prevent
you from like missing some gigantic
important thing. Like for instance, I
didn't know what hashing was when I got
to undergrad. I just missed that.
It's actually a well-known professor
told me he had the exact same thing
happen.
Um, so that's what that's for.
Man,
get like a protein shake or something.
Take a break. Let me try a couple last
things here before I do though.
I'm just hungry. I haven't eaten
anything yet today.
Some like snacks or something in the
middle of the day.
It's not a cheat sheet of syntax.
If you're brand new, you kind of need to
be like you can't just be like four
iterates. Like that's not a useful cheat
sheet. You need to be taught the basics
of control flow, boolean logic,
um function calling.
So this thing here, right? This worked.
This doesn't change at all.
So I mean we can see here this is the
correct example right the weight changes
a whole bunch
and in the incorrect example at least
now we have a Okay,
still doing Tiny Grad stuff, man. It's a
good library. Um, I like a lot of the
things. Uh, the way it is at the moment,
it's going to take me some more work to
figure out if I want to like pop kernels
out of it or whatnot. I'm doing foodraph
at the moment because right now we're
mostly limited by launch overhead
and like I can't just use tiny because
like tiny won't let me optimize to the
level that I'd like.
I think if Tiny Gr were just written in
C and be able to just use it, but it's
not, man.
Dang. You know, I was pretty
I thought that might actually work.
Exactly right, Eric. Like
if these things worked,
the world would look very different
immediately,
It's like I've invented teleportation.
Oh, it's like, well,
why you taking a plane then
is dumb. All right, I'm here to rest
real quick. I got to get myself
something with calories in it so I can
continue on this. Uh, the current bug
for anyone wondering.
So, we have it that you can trace the
train loop.
um the traced function when you're not
calling it with capture works correctly
but then when you try to replay it the
uh the parameters don't change.
So something got screwed up here. I
don't know if it's like a pointer's
getting overwritten or something
I swear the last two days of dev has
been like
write five lines of code. Encounter evil
bug of doom with no error messenger
stack trace. Isolate a evil bug of doom.
Fix evil bug of doom.
Double check. Yes, there were literally
no docs, no examples, no anything that I
could have possibly referred to to fix
evil bug of doom.
Ported 100%
all the way up to the main menu.
Let's see.
Oh,
cool.
Wait, what are you doing?
Are you like looking at the assembly and
trying to port it to sea?
Interesting.
Similarly to Zig.
Music is fine as well. Whatever.
Cool.
I mean, if you actually do get this
thing to be like fully implemented and
fast, it will be very cool.
Like, if you can get this to the speed
of the actual puffer ms, this would be a
very, very nice one for RL.
is awesome. It sucks that there's no um
no way to get like a general purpose
emulator that fast still, but even just
having like the one Pokemon game would
still be amazing.
Like that'd be a really good end.
Mic is a little quiet.
I was leaning forward.
protein, hot chocolate.
And that would be very big.
I will await your progress.
Big cup.
Yep.
Okay. So,
last evil bug of doom for a while
hopefully.
You know what we can do?
I want to try something.
Zidus for Pentium.
What does that mean? Be back when we can
battle.
I did.
I'm not enjoying my grass. This is
miserable. But I am fresh off a
vacation, so I can endure this for a
little bit.
Yeah, Jess, I don't think there's a way
to do that.
I think you're way better off just
trying to make it substantially less
work than it is now.
Like we technically have that in the
sense that it'll just flatten it and run
something for you, but making one that's
actually good, that's like not really
doable,
at least not efficiently. There are
tokenizer type approaches. Uh they
produce very inefficient encodings
though usually
Next what we do is
right I was going to print out
We could definitely do like a which ones
are hot or whatever visualizer. There's
a lot of stuff we can do.
See if this prints the whole thing or
prints the address.
What I miss
fighting to him
The careful viewer may ask, "What the
hell am I doing?"
To that I say,
I'm trying to see if the freaking memory
address moves.
right. So before I capture it
and after I capture it
Okay, this is our initial memory
address. You see?
Oops.
It doesn't move.
The memory address does not move.
So then how the heck is it screwing
I forgot to increase the key repeat
speed on this machine.
I was wondering why it's so freaking
slow.
Where is it?
They got rid of it apparently. That's
annoying as hell.
It's going to make a really aggressive
update.
You know what?
Try something else.
See if it changes during capture at
least.
Six. 67 56. Right.
All right. So, here's my question.
Here's my question. How?
Right.
Let me just try something.
I had um an idea.
I think I just misunderstood how the
graphs work.
That is still an evil evil evil bug if
I'm correct.
I'm making progress.
67. What?
No,
I do not know his doomer meme.
I am old.
Very old. Ancient in fact.
phone screen time today. I literally
don't even know how to do that.
Yeah, I don't even know where the hell
that is.
You'll know I've really made it in life
when I no longer own a phone.
All professional inquiries are to be
directed by carrier pigeon.
What if I just run that function once,
right?
What if I just do like forward?
Is it train
forward call?
If I just do this thing, what happens?
I use Vim the way I use everything else.
Like I don't use all the fancy features.
Actually, the biggest thing is I need to
fix this is a new machine. I need to um
increase the key repeat speed. That's
about it.
Open front end.
Make sure that you think about the obs
and actions bases, Jeff.
And what about chess?
I want to see the chess thing work.
Okay, look at this. Okay, look at this,
guys. So, this is what I was looking
for. If I run this function, okay,
the value changes.
I'm going to put one more here just to
show you.
I think we can figure it out just from
this.
Okay, good. We need the thoughtless
stuff, man.
What?
Excuse me? What?
This thing is messing with me.
What's messing with me?
I think we just accidentally figured it
out,
which is so bizarre.
So, let me see if I just don't do this
cuz it's failed.
Is it like not warming up properly
somehow?
Maybe it was this and I messed up the
test.
Oh, okay.
We found it. We found it. I don't know
how I messed it up in the test earlier,
but yeah, it's this.
Okay,
so apparently these coefficients
these just go into the CUDA graph
and you can't change these at all. Okay,
bird IDE this one.
That's so funny that I just post this
thing and this is of all things blows
up.
It does not produce new code. What the
hell is this? Wix
cloudbased web development services. The
[ __ ] Oh,
and I'm supposed to take Yeah, no thank
you.
Whatever, man.
If you're enjoying the uh
suffering through cudigraph,
go ahead and start this puffer. He likes
stars.
She you need to be fed right here. This
number go up.
Feed the puffer.
double check one thing and then I will
implement the rest of this fix
and then it will work and we shall be
happy.
Hey.
Okay.
So, how we do this? Uh oh. Uhoh.
Um,
this mean
You know, let me this is a this is
actually now a broad question.
Let's actually just make sure before we
break anything else, you know,
This one not getting traced somehow.
New value
Yeah, that's 9 mil though if we get
that. So without this Come on.
Okay, so that runs.
Now we got to figure out what the heck.
Okay. So, you can't have these scalers
apparently.
Cool.
What do we do? Convert these to
to GPU buffers.
We're going to get a full prototype of
this done today.
These guys, right?
All these params
Okay,
we'll double check these, but um
Okay.
8.7 mil
speed. Now we need to get the advantage.
Was it um mean and
whatever it is?
We're going to do that as a separate
stream. Crap. Um, we're going to do that
as a separate stream
9 million, guys. 9 million.
Almost there. Going to make a quick
commit.
right. So, let's figure this out. All
right.
I have a hypothesis.
now, this fuse PO loss needs
modification.
Right. This needs modification.
Let's
popular for ASV UV results were great.
Cool. Glad to hear. Yeah,
I've seen you in chat.
My brain is currently cudographing at
the moment.
We are on hour, what is this? I did 10
yesterday. So, this is about We're
entering hour 16 in the last 36 hours of
cudigraphs.
That should give you an idea of the vibe
at the moment.
I mean,
this is actually kind of impressive. The
more I'm thinking about it, if we're
going to hit 10 mil in float 32,
that's pretty freaking good, right?
I think that speed float's still
unstable for now with this, but like
you know, we hit this in float 32 and
then some numerical stability work down
the line, maybe we get 16.
Good to see it.
Have to take a short intermission
relatively soon.
the backwards.
It up.
See what this saved
saved kernel is.
Stuff is tricky.
Okay, this is how it is. Look, you see?
doing here.
It's supposed to be I just have to
figure out how to like pass this back,
right?
Okay. How do I do that?
I
Okay. So this is the forward pass
and then you get it.
Oh, you know what?
You can just put stuff in here, can't
you?
So, can I just do what if I just do this
for terms?
Can just do like this, right?
actually avoids a graph break. Funny
enough,
this could be a no graph break train
loop.
Is this the full thing?
I mean, there's some like some sketchy
bits with it, but um I think this is it.
I see.
Yeah, that's our replay.
And yeah, that's the fuse loss.
Okay. Um,
it's the entire friend loop, guys.
That's pretty cool.
Do we call this commented?
Didn't break it. This will eat a few
SPS.
Actually, this Well, I think this can be
a higher per.
We'll try this.
This is going to break. We're going to
be happy.
That trains
8 point. Oh, there you go. Nine 9 9
million SPF.
Okay, I'm going to run profile and I'm
going to commit this
I'm going to take a quick break as well.
Um, and then I think that the plan is
I'm going to be
here until about 5:30. Maybe
I got a thing to get to by 6.
20 30 minutes away.
Yeah. Okay. As long as this finishes,
I'll leave this up on the screen and um
I'll be back in a second. Few minutes,
actually.
Look at that.
There's still a ton of launches. We're
down to 10K. We'll figure out why
there's still 10K. I'll be back.
We'll get our time out.
Let's
[sighs]
graph synchronizations.
Oh, I know what that's from, though.
That's fine.
way lower, right?
So we're saying there's 366 ms CUDA
400 ms CPU.
What is CUDA stream [clears throat] for
right here?
What happens without the CUDA device
synchronized?
Okay. So, notably, right, this is not
faster.
Okay, I'm going to actually toss this
rock in a second.
Launch kernel
one device synchronization. You see
that?
Beautiful.
Okay. So what happens?
What happens with this?
So one device synchronization
and before we had two device synchronize
57ms CPU.
Okay.
So 50 at 7 MS CPU.
Now we have 8 MS CPU.
Uh we did drop like 20ish ms.
I think at least a good chunk of that
time is phantom.
stream query?
You saw it. What?
Actually, I'm going to give I'm gonna
just chuck this into
Does these add up?
Because it's 370 ms, right? So, this is
190.
This is already above um this exceeds
the Oh, wait. 377 ms.
Yeah, this is all already over 400 in
these lines here.
Um, let me try one other thing.
Let's try one other thing. All right,
guys. Hang on.
Me try something.
We're going to disable the end
and we're going to see if that cleans up
the profile.
We can do a couple things actually with
that.
Okay. So, how much faster does it get
with no end?
Look, it doesn't actually get faster,
meaning that it's fully async. We're not
really bottlenecked.
Maybe a few hundred thousand maybe.
Not major though for the whole end which
is cool.
Then we're going to do profile
and then we're going to see if the CUDA
stream query is shut up because um I
think those are all coming from the end
and they're being done on thread and
then they're getting added up.
We still have the CUD to stream query is
this like all the overhead
list of all latencies. Well, I have to
figure out which of these is um
overhead.
They still don't add up, right? No,
wait. Maybe they do.
Uh, let me just look at there's
So wait, we got five of these.
And then this is what? 640 mf
It's 4 mil.
This profile overhead like mad.
Well, one thing we can do is
how fast run.
That is actually close to the real
runtime, right?
Maybe that's
maybe we need answers.
Okay, here's this.
We get elementwise kernel.
And now we get like a pretty clean
we get like pretty clean long tail,
right?
With view scan actually being element
wise view scan.
Poppy. A little bit of poppy overhead.
Oh, it doesn't. It doesn't like Hang on.
Let me fix that.
Get a good profile. Come on.
I need a table.
This exit cleanly.
I don't think so. Right. This should be
done.
And I think that the TW one is just way
too much overhead.
There's literally nothing interesting on
this.
But maybe hang on. Maybe we can do this
now.
Oh, that is something just incredibly
stupid.
Hey Fabia, welcome.
This jokes of me very tired fight
demons.
I'm being just a mass goober, but
whatever.
Oh, there we go. That's a proper graph.
Lovely.
That worked.
I actually should know how that works,
but I don't.
I should totally I don't know that works
by I think it's like second stream, but
I don't know how that actually map.
See if that does anything.
These are nice tables. This is exactly
what I want.
Oh, there it is.
So, Grock didn't work. But I can make
use of this.
No, we got it. It's all right there.
Right.
CUDA launch kernel.
CUDA graph launch.
Wait. 92k 98,000 kernels. Oh, no. This
is actually fine, right?
Actually, no. These add up perfectly,
right?
So, nanoconds
is E12, right?
No. 1 billion.
Okay.
So, let's do
let's do something about this.
and I want to see if this makes sense.
Okay, 229 epox, right?
We're trying to monitor how many kernel
launches there are.
Okay. So this is look 10,000
10,000 kernel launches
for this is five epochs worth of
profiling. Five
and what did we say that there were
229.
So we take this number
we multiply this by like 40ish.
So, we should have somewhere around
400,000 Infernal launches.
Oops.
We get
[snorts]
average NS. That's
ridiculously high, isn't it?
No, wait. That's 12.
Oh, but what what is this?
These graph launches are so expensive.
This is 1 second.
Can I sum these easily? I don't think I
can.
Oh, wait. 17 1.4.
Scan forward.
Is this still profiling everything
though?
This is
inside Python.
So
You can already run this on Python
though. It's just going to profile the
internal
balls, right?
35 micros.
Now we have what's this? This is 7
seconds spent on So there's no way this
is actually 7 seconds. I like this adds
up to the program time exactly.
native unrolled element wise vectorzed
gather kernel.
I no longer see my graphs in here.
Yeah. So, my graphs,
unless it's one of these unrolled
element wise kernel, I wouldn't have
done that, right?
Pretty much. Yeah.
I'm just I'm trying to figure out what
is launch overhead and what's real. And
it's kind of difficult, you know.
I before I grouped by graph I saw
individual kernels of mine but like now
which of these are actually my graph
right
per
what view does that give me
I want aggregate. Does this give me
aggregate?
I just want average kernel timings
and like graph timings, right? Timeline
area. I don't want that, dude. That
doesn't help me.
This has got to be one of my graphs,
right?
Native GPU kernel impul.
This has to be one of my graphs.
Is this display?
What display? This is NSIS.
No, man. This is NSIS.
The shell script is just like up. It's
just an NSIS run. Yeah, I'd like to be
able to annotate. That's what I want to
figure out. That would be helpful.
Unlike
see a lot. Yeah, it is. It's way lighter
though than um Torch's profiler.
I don't know what the hell Torch is
doing.
Like there's got to be a way to label it
now.
Pulse stacks. Well, what I want to do,
dude, is I want to label um I just want
to label my graphs, you know, so I can
see
Like you see what I'm trying to do,
right? Like I just want to have
visibility on everything. So, you know,
now we have things chucked into graphs.
I want to know what's my launch
overhead, what's the time spent in
graphs. The idea is just like nobody
actually really profiles their code in
RL like ever, right? Like nobody
actually knows where the time loss is.
Um because if you do like the Python
profiler, there's so much overhead in
that that with RL, you're literally just
measuring the profiler. Um,
it's actually very difficult to figure
out what is profiler overhead versus
what is real. It's difficult to
understand like overlapping of launch
calls versus anything else.
in the way of owning the language
service
the compiler as well.
I I just need to profile man.
It's really not that complicated what
I'm trying to do.
Oh, we are at like 9 million SPS though,
so
pretty good.
This should be available. No.
buffer out of bounds
built into the language.
You don't need to build that into the
language though
I don't really have that many like
language level problems honestly.
supposed to be. So the lack of
transparency with profiling is just lack
of docs and possibly small lack of
features on tools. There's nothing
language level that's the problem here
at the moment.
overworld rendering is in. Awesome. What
about the base in speed, man? Like the
rendering is awesome, but the most
important thing is the um the tick
speed, right? Because like we can
technically train from state.
You'd have to get the state up to
well, you have all the cores on the oned
machine. Technically,
the problem is the factor of 24 that
comes from the uh the skip in that game.
So like 24 million aggregate would give
us 1 million step per second sim
effective.
I think it's definitely possible. Like I
don't believe looking at Pokemon the
game like there can't possibly be that
much stuff going on under the hood
that's not for audio and rendering,
right? Because you don't have to sim
that
whatever we want. Yeah.
It's a factor of the emulator.
No, it isn't. Right.
No, you have to fundamentally like it's
an old game. Presumably, the tick system
is hardcoded, right?
24 emulator ticks.
Yeah, but aren't those games written
that way? Like,
I'm pretty sure those games are written
to be very tied to the tick rate, man. I
could be wrong, but I don't think like
they're not in any way tied to real time
as far as I know. I think they're tied
to that tick rate.
That was a number Peter.
No. No. So the 24. So I understand that
the 24 is arbitrary, but like
24 is there's a it's the frame rate.
It's tied to the frame rate, right? Like
it's the amount of time. It wasn't for
one button press. I thought it was the
amount of time to cross one tile, wasn't
it?
Yeah, I'm still live.
I got to go in like 20 minutes, but I'm
live for now.
I mean, regardless, it's the real time
speed is the thing that ultimately
matters because for that game, you're
taking actions at a rate of one or two
per second's worth of real time
gameplay.
Like, you can't just
You can't just take actions more
frequently and have it be higher SPS,
right?
Yeah, but it's not like fully from
scratch, man. It's still a direct
or the rendering.
I like I guess technically yeah, you
could make it so that instead of the
agent moving like a small distance in
one ticket moves a bigger distance. That
would be a pretty big win. It would
probably mess with other things. Like
there are things you can do. I think you
can make it fast enough though anyways
frankly.
Like you can definitely get 24 mil per
core if you want to and then have it be
super fast. There's not that much going
on in Pokemon, right?
Like what do you actually have to
process every tick under the hood? Not
very much.
So, I don't I don't think that you
really have to do um
very much
to get it fast. Like, the hard part is
obviously that it's it's got to be
ported.
I actually don't understand why the
emulator is so slow either. I like I
don't understand enough about emulators
to know why that thing is so slow, you
know?
Oops.
Why? Like Also slow
Large switch case.
Why is which case.
Can you not just like map the
instruction to an index or whatever?
There's got to be Can't you like store
them as indices or something?
There's no way that you need to have be
a big like switch table, right?
It should just end up being an array
lookup. No.
I'd have to look at it as to like That
can't just be cuz like the standard
trick is to just turn it into an array.
No.
Okay, this runs
Yeah, I don't know enough to say.
I mean, you know, I'm not going to be
the type to just say, "Oh, well, it
sounds like it can't be any faster
without knowing." But
it is a fairly wellstudied area, I'd
say. But like I don't know, maybe
there's something smart you can do. Who
knows?
I'd have to at least spend some time
with it.
Yeah. What am I supposed to do with
this, man?
Run. Okay, that's a fine idea.
Um,
okay. There is something in here. Roll
out.
There's got to be a command though to
get it.
Literally open the file select.
Well, I don't know how it actually
stores the logs, man. But like I should
Is there not something I can do?
Oh, look at that.
That's great. Look at this.
Okay, I think this is what we're going
to have to do next. Right, this will be
the next thing. Um, but the the result
from today is quite good.
So, we got upwards of 9 million steps
per second. Uh, we're very close to the
end goal here.
We need to do some profiling to
understand the remaining bottlenecks.
We're able to get the entire training uh
the entire like training of the whole
network with one
device synchronized
excluding the environment syncs which
are going to be able to not be full
syncs.
So
I'd say this has been quite productive.
Um,
9 million steps per second though. We're
almost there, guys.
Almost there. Um, if I can just add some
amounts of annotations
that let us like monitor a few sections
of the code when we have a profiling
mode on and just get us a nice little
table with the major overhead
categories.
We should be able to optimize very
nicely.
I've got to go because I got to get
ready. I got to go get to dinner. I got
to go pick somebody up as well. Um,
for folks watching, thank you for tuning
in. I will probably do another stream
tomorrow, pending things. Uh, if you're
interested in my stuff, generally I
stream all my dev, all my research
pretty much. Uh, all this stuff is open
source at puffer.ai. AI
if you are interested here. Star the
repo. Feed the puffer a star. He likes
stars.
He's hungry. It helps me a lot. Discord
if you want to get involved. Nice
community here. You can follow me on X
for more RL content including
announcements and such.